I want to start today as we have many
days in the last week and talk about the
Russian invasion of Ukraine but I want
to zoom out a little bit and take a
little bit more of like a systemic big
picture 30 000 foot view you know one of
the goals of Vladimir Putin and Russia
uh for more than a decade now in Earnest
and you could argue really even longer
than that is to weaken what's seen as
the West the United States and Europe or
you know you could sort of characterize
it uh in in a number of different ways
weaken the West make the United States
and Western democracy look uh weaker or
in question or untrustworthy in some way
and the general goal of this is to make
Russia look better in comparison I mean
this is a very basic and sort of crude
way to say it but when you think about
the three major superpowers the United
States Russia and China
the worse any one of them looks the
better by comparison others look and so
when we think back to the Trump era and
we wonder or or we don't really have to
wonder but we I think about why Putin
would want and benefited from Trump
rather than Hillary Clinton being
president and chaos electorally and
claims about voter fraud and all these
things why does Putin benefit from that
well when you step back and look at the
three major Powers if the U.S looks
silly
if the U.S looks stupid if the U.S looks
so ignorant that there are enough people
that they would vote for a clown like
Trump by comparison it makes Russia look
better
and one of the main goals of Putin in
general is to make the the west and the
U.S look worse and the most the more
fragmented that the West is uh the
weaker that it appears to be and
unfortunately for Putin his invasion of
Ukraine has sort of accidentally or as a
side effect unified and strengthened the
West to the extent that the West is now
very clear with some exceptions you know
you turn on Fox News you'll see pro pro
Putin apologia but for the most part
Putin's invasion of Ukraine has actually
had the unintended consequence of
unifying and strengthening the West
there's an interesting article that you
can check out uh by Holly Elliot on CNBC
called Putin's always wanted to weaken
the West he's done the exact opposite
and the article actually explains if
there's anything we've learned about
Putin over the 22 years he's been in
power
it's that he is systematically and
repeatedly tried to weaken and undermine
the west but in his invasion of Ukraine
he seems to have achieved the exact
opposite managing to unite most of the
International Community in its
condemnation of Russia's aggression
towards its neighbor Ian bremmer
president of political risk consultancy
Eurasia group commented quote NATO is
United more so than at any point since
the Soviet collapse with a renewed sense
of purpose and Mission so too is the
European Union Germany supports ending
their economic dependence on Russia and
is nearly doubling their defense spend
France is on board even Moscow tilting
Hungary has condemned The Invasion
favored a crippling sanctions regime and
is allowing in hundreds of thousands of
Ukrainian refugees refugees the West is
used to Russia behaving like a malign
actor
um uh over time it's also widely seen as
responsible for uh rather it also sees
Russia as responsible for a nerve agent
attack on UK soil in 2018 and was
subsequently sanctioned and it goes on
to explain that this may have been in a
sense the worst unintended consequence
of what Putin is doing now Putin may end
up dead at the end of this entire thing
we don't know Putin may end up deposed
out of power we don't know Putin may end
up taking Ukraine we we don't know at
this point in time but the way in which
this has unified the West over the long
term is not particularly good for
Putin's bigger picture Ambitions now
there's another aspect to this which
we've seen at the David pakman show and
I've talked to some other Independent
Media people and everybody's seeing the
same thing over the last 10 to 14 days
there has been a notable decline in a
certain strain of Bot type right wing
trolling all over our platforms I'm
talking YouTube Twitter Reddit Etc there
has been for the last many years
um a suspicious amount of comments like
I'm as liberal as the next guy but and
then they use some like right-wing
argument to try to make it seem as
though even left Wingers are skeptical
of the American left and all this
different stuff you know stuff like um
uh listen uh uh I I'm I'm a foreigner
and I just don't understand why is
having a needing a photo ID such a bad
thing for voting you need an ID for
everything else oh these repetitive
sorts of messages that we see posted on
all of our platforms they have
diminished dramatically in the last 10
to 14 days now I don't think it's
because they are all
Russian Trolls but we know that Russia
for a long time has waged pretty slick
uh sort of disinformation type campaigns
online all over the world and shows like
ours have absolutely uh been affected by
them if you look at any of our platforms
that is down dramatically it seems
because they are uh
at least to some degree
uh preoccupied with trying to justify
this invasion of Ukraine and the next
months presumably will give us a sense
of is Russia heading towards annexing
Ukraine or installing a public
government is Russia heading in the
opposite direction of going in the
direction of a truly failed state for a
long time with a broken economy that
remains to be seen But Putin succeeded
at calling into question American
democracy when Trump won and then when
they fomented the big lie ideas that
Trump won again in 2020 even though he
didn't he he succeeded at that he really
did but without a doubt to some degree
the biggest unintentioned unintended
consequence of the Russian invasion of
Ukraine is that much of the West is now
as United as it has been in a really
really long time Putin may end up taking
Ukraine we just don't know yet and I
think anybody who
leans on the inevitability of one
outcome or the other there's people who
are saying listen sooner or later
Putin's gonna get Ukraine I don't think
that that's uh something we can
accurately say on the other hand you
have the perspective that sooner or
later Russia is going to get just
absolutely crushed here and Putin will
be removed killed whatever I don't think
that that's a foregone conclusion either
I don't think we know the answer but uh
when you see the West as United as it is
it doesn't bode particularly well for
Russia one of our sponsors is called
privacy privacy is a totally free
service that I've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when I use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say I'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up I can delete that
virtual card so I know I'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy C is
a totally free service and you'll get
five bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video